[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
these lying [__]
I don't know if you watched some flips
from the Sunday show we're going to
watch those clips today
manga is the cultist
fascist
group of liars
and Defenders of those cult lies
uh it's kind of crazy that um we can't
just
agree on a simple set of facts I know
I've been saying this sort of thing over
and over again and that's probably
because it's just the truth
look
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
Kevin weak ass non-speaker of the house
McCarthy
you have to base your opinions with a
certain set of facts if you don't it's
just wild beliefs pulled straight out of
your stupid asses
Now Kevin McCarthy and Jim Jordan know
exactly what they're doing
they know exactly what they're doing
they know why they're doing it
they know how they're doing it
they know what the end result well
they're desired in result is with what
they're doing
with spreading their lies and
misinformation now the question is
does the media have them on these Sunday
shows to do this
and Margaret Brennan did a pretty good
job
of Smashing up Kevin McCarthy on his
[__] lies and his deceit
and his attempt to mind [__] American
people
Chuck Todd normally
um does not do a good job he totally
[__] it up Chuck Todd you suck and it
sucks this sucks so but I will say he
gave a half-hearted attempt
to put Jim Jordan in his place the
problem is is that
Chuck Todd Morgan Margaret Brennan and
the rest of the media just absolutely do
not see the danger
of which these these [__] cultists
are using these lies to perpetuate the
demise of our democracy
they're just Republican ah they're just
they're I mean they're they're elected
officials so they must not be dangerous
they're rhetoric their lies must not be
dangerous
foreign
but they are
we are in an age
where
information
is King
so much so that we have information
Warfare
happening all around the world
using the minds
and the Free Will of people
to delude them into thinking things that
are just certainly
not true
we were told
oh we're not gonna get rid of libraries
we're not trying to get rid of schools
we're not trying to get rid of all the
books we just don't like these Five
Books five of them you know a handful
right
because they humanize certain groups of
people and we don't want children to be
indoctrinated
into believing that people from the
lgbtq community are people of color
should are humans
and be one what the you want to ban the
books because of what
well you know
lgbtq and people of color are totally
sexual
I mean it's anything to do with them is
sexual what what are you talking about
the lgbtq community in a bipod Community
their existence is not inherently sexual
you stupid bastards
but they convinced The Cult of this
through bigotry
through their racist bias they're
bigoted bias
their religion
and they convinced these people that not
all not only are the books bad
but if people read you any book any book
especially if they're dressed up in a
costume performing trying to get kids
interested in reading that is totally
sexual and it is denigrating or it is
deteriorating our society
they moved to that right
ban a few books ban people reading books
and now in Florida they're absolutely
taking books out of entire libraries
I read a tweet and I actually retweeted
it this morning uh Jim Stewardson we've
had Jim on the show before
um he
he really pisses General if you want to
call him that we should strip him of
that [__] title Mike Flynn I don't
know if you know who Michael Flynn is
he was a national security advisor
he was charged in crimes and Trump
pardoned him from those crimes
to make sure that criminal could walk
the streets
and push his Maga religion on all of us
now
you say what in the [__]
does Mike Flynn have to do
with the lies that Kevin McCarthy
and Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
is telling
on Sunday shows it has everything to do
with it
what what do you think these lies are
intended for
their the intent is to protect Trump
the entirety of every single lie that
the Republican Party tells in this day
and age is designed to protect their
orange Mussolini Jesus folks he's going
to be their nominee
in 2024
he will probably be under criminal
indictment
for a slew of crimes that range from
Financial crimes
to trying to overthrow our election
but he's gonna be their Nama knee
he's the king of lies he's the king of
the cult
why wouldn't he be
what do you think Mike Flynn's running
around the country doing he's paying the
price of the pardon
by whipping up these white Christian
nationalists into a frenzy of Lies
this Reawakening campaign have you seen
these [__] tours these and these just
this [__] Deus of [__]
and Jim Stewardson points it out this
morning where Mike Flynn tweets that he
wants he wants his cult
he wants his cult to homeschool their
children
they know they know they're not going to
be able to take
all the information
out of the works right now like they
understand that they're still going to
be truth somewhere
there is still Liberty in our country
they haven't eroded it away completely
yet
in all states
that's their goal
but they haven't gotten there yet so
what they need to do is keep their cult
close they need to keep their cult
followers close
and they need to keep them in an ultra
Ultra diluted State that's why they call
themselves Ultra manga because they're
Ultra diluted
believing all the great lies
and one of the key points to this
is to make sure that elected officials
go on mainstream media
and parrot
that narrative and those lies to protect
the cult leader that is Trump
that's the entire purpose their entire
party is a cult if you have an R next to
your name and you are an elected
official are trying to get elected you
are a member of the cult I don't give a
[__] if you don't like Trump I don't
give a [__] if you don't like McCarthy I
don't give a [__] what you do and don't
like if you got an R next to your name
you are a goddamn member of the fascist
cult that is Maga
that's you
now there's all kinds of [__]
[__] polls out there and the media
keeps repeating these [__] polls
over and over and over again I wish they
would shut the [__] up about these
dumbass
[__] poles listen folks until we have a
situation where we can actually rely on
what polls are saying do not listen to
them they are so full of [__] [__]
just absolutely full of [__] [__] and
the right uses them when the media
[__] starts talking about them they
use them to their advantage to try to
convince the cult to be deeper in their
delusion
again I've I've said it a million times
I'll probably say it a million more
we are not divided 50 50. that's the
problem we got
we are not divided half and half in this
country
half love democracy the other half want
to smash it up that's all [__]
the majority of people in this country
buy a large number want democracy they
want freedom they want Liberty now
the problem is a large percentage of
that majority
doesn't know how it's delivered it's a
problem but we're getting there there's
a small percentage of people in this
country and it's a large number of
people it's just a smaller percentage
that absolutely want to destroy our
country
they want to destroy it they want to
destroy democracy they do not want
Liberty for all they do not want to quit
Equity they do not want equality Jesus
Christ they went on and on and on on
Twitter this weekend I don't know how
many times I saw a [__] tweet that
said why is it that can someone tell me
in a serious way why five black police
officers killing a black man is white
supremacy you are a dumb [__]
you need to go dust off the [__]
dictionary and look up words
I'm gonna try to explain it today
and from my experience
as a white person who grew up in the in
in the great institution of whiteness
you [__] boneheads of course five
black officers
tracking down and murdering a young
black man with their [__] bare hands
not rendering him Aid
standing around like like he was a feral
hog that they hunted and killed
bragging about it how they [__] threw
hate makers
how they beat the [__] out of him how
they sprayed him over and over and over
with Mason tazed him
and you not knowing
that the badge that they're wearing
is the institution
that oppresses black people you stupid
[__] just because the person
wearing the [__] badge is black does
not mean that that institution and that
situation
and that unfortunate death is not a
result of our white supremacy in our
institutions in this country you are a
stupid [__] and you have not
been listening
it's not Matt walshed this stupid [__]
oh it's not the leftists don't want to
talk about the killing of of Tyree
Nichols oh look there's not as many
demonstrations in the street as there
was with George Floyd because it's not
racially motivated what are you talking
about
Matt Walsh you dumb [__]
there's no more racial motivation
then five black cops
who used the institution listen listen
listen to me real [__] good
turn it up
right now
if Tyree Nichols name was Justin Smith
and he was white they would never they
would never have tracked him down and
killed him and treated him like they
just hunted a feral hog that there is no
[__] way
those [__] knew they could get
away with brutalizing him knew they
could get away with killing him for one
reason and one reason only
Tyree Nichols is a black man that's why
and it's not racially motivated [__] you
Matt Walsh [__] you you racist bigot
[__]
you gaslighting stupid son of a [__]
I meant to wait to get into The Tyree
Nichols but I can't help it I can't I
[__] watched I waited I waited until
this morning
to watch the video I didn't even watch
it over the weekend
I went and I I listened to other
people's responses of the video I wanted
to know what their experience was what
their thoughts was of the video before I
even set my eyes on it
me as a white man it does not [__]
matter it doesn't matter what my what it
doesn't matter Matt Walsh what your
opinion is what my opinion is
about race
you stupid [__] because if it was you
you white [__] if it was your
cracker ass they would never never would
have blocked five black cops in Memphis
tracked you down and beat you to death
and bragged about it on body cams you
piece of [__] garbage
not racially motivated what on what
[__] planet do you [__] live
you even said it in your Tweet you dumb
bastard
oh people were way more outraged about
George Floyd
yes because he was murdered
by a cop
to Snuff the life out of him with his
knee and that cop was white but guess
what
there were other non-white cops standing
there
flooding letting Derek Chauvin snuffed
the life out of George Floyd you stupid
[__] idiot Matt Walsh you dirty
[__] you vile piece of trash
ignoring that fact
ignoring the fact
that there were non-white officers
standing watching him do it and the
reason why is because of the white
institution of law enforcement
and why we have the white institution of
law enforcement in this country I don't
give a [__] what race these officers are
it's a white institution and it's design
from its very Inception
is to make sure that white supremacy
lives in the authoritarian realm of law
enforcement
and if you don't know that
if you don't know that then you have not
listened to people of color's experience
with law enforcement in this country you
just have not listened maybe they talked
but you didn't [__] hear them
Matt Walsh and me being white were
crackers we're white Saltine salty
[__] crackers
we do not have the experience
of people of color with law enforcement
Matt
it's not a [__] thing were white the
system is designed to protect us and
kill them
it doesn't matter the race of the
officer frankly maybe it does matter and
the reason why it matters is because it
makes it oh it makes it less less like
less white oh it's less oh well it can't
be white supremacists I mean they're
black
as if the race of the person
perpetuating right white supremacy has
anything to do with the institution that
killed Tyree Nichols
and if you don't see that if you don't
know that you didn't watch the tape you
haven't been listening for people for
decades all the way back to Rodney King
you haven't been listening
they've been talking they've been saying
it listen I told you this
black folks are not afraid to talk to
you about racism they are [__] not
afraid of it
all you have to do is open your [__]
ears and hear them
listen to their experience
and I'm not talking about
these [__] token black people they
bring on
Fox News
to make sure to undermine
the racial component in law enforcement
and the white supremacy that is
perpetuated by it to conf oh look order
well look I got a black friend and he he
says this I mean I had to seek him out
and find him and make sure that he says
the correct thing that I want him to say
on Tucker Carlson's show
Jason Whittle
law enforcement in this country
and I didn't know this I didn't I mean I
never liked cops all right I don't I I
mean I never had an affinity for cops
[__] cops [__] them [__] the police [__]
them
but never in my life when I was growing
up
did I understand
what law enforcement in this country was
designed for
why why why my white Community had no
people of color in it
it was because white people in that
community did not want people of color
and law enforcement were there to
protect them to make sure there weren't
you ever heard of a Sundown town
who do you think enforced that
who do you think what [__] white
supremacist do you think enforce the
Sundown laws in towns in white towns I
don't know if you know what A Sundown
law is
but on the edge of white towns in Rural
America
not that long ago in this lifetime
[__] there was a sign that said
Don't Let the Sun hit your back
if you're black
most of them
throughout way way worse
racial epithets and tropes
but that's the gist of it
do not be outside do not be wandering
around the town in the dark if you're
black
who do you think can force those who do
you thinking board enforce that Sundown
law hmm who do you think it
get white people who do you think it was
Matt Walsh
huh
you think it was all the farmers with
pitchforks no
it was the white supremacist institution
of law enforcement in that town
and in 2023 boy it's so convenient oh
it's so convenient it's oh it's just
magnificent that they can hide the
institution's white supremacy by making
sure they they drag black people into
the culture
and make sure when a young man gets
killed because he's black
murdered by five police officers because
he's black that they're black too that
makes it real convenient for the white
narrative in this country to keep
perpetuating the white supremacy that is
in law enforcement and the [__] lies
the [__] lies The Cult of Lies
it really is funny that the same people
who deny
that Joe Biden won the presidential
election in 2020
and and believe in their heart of hearts
that Donald Trump won because of
machines and my pillow said this and
Mike Flynn prayed us on that
same [__]
same [__] that are excited
that the five officers that killed and
murdered Tyree Nichols hunted him down
like a feral hog and bragged about their
game
same [__]
it's the same same [__] that
are of the cult of lies that are excited
about the LIE
the lie that Tyree Nichols
would be alive today
Tyree Nichols would be alive today
if he were white everyone stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
it's Monday January 30th holy [__]
January almost done
I told you we gotta get to work we have
to work on our democracy every single
day we cannot let up
it's already a whole month's gone by
and we're barreling towards 2024 yes I
know it it's like Tony God damn we're
not even in February yet you're talking
about how we're getting towards I'm
telling you you're gonna turn around
tomorrow and I'm gonna be saying hey
[__]
hey he won this primary he won that
primary
and then we're gonna get to the
conventions in 2024 and Donald Trump's
going to be the nominee
and you're gonna holy [__] that was fast
that was fast
and you're going to turn around what you
could have done for our democracy it's
really simple it's not you don't do a
lot
again we're going to win in 2024.
with messaging and narrative
simple it's simple
if we have the right messaging and
narrative we can drive people to the
polls if you get people to go
participate in their ballot
we will we will make sure to head off
fascism in our democracy once again
now we didn't do it fully in 2022 but we
did a damn good job
we did a damn good job
especially facing
what could have been a complete disaster
the Senate and the house now we have an
averted disaster because
Kevin McCarthy has sold his entire
speakership away to his conference he
admits it to Margaret Brennan over the
weekend totally says it out loud says it
out [__] loud I'm gonna show it to
you I think it's one of the most
significant parts
of the clip and the reason why is
because he doesn't lie
like he's dealt with a lot of [__]
lies in this clip like the guy's like
lie lie like you get a lie you get a lie
you get a lie
but when he comes down to the question
of putting putting [__] domestic
terrorists
on our [__] house committees
he admits something
he admits something he admits it and I I
think he's telling the truth
as rare as that may be for Kevin
McCarthy but I'm going to show you the
clip it's a it's a long clip we're gonna
break it down here we also are gonna
break down a clip of Chuck Todd trying
his best
trying his best to fact check
and check Jim Jordan he does a little
better job than he normally does but
he's still he still didn't get it right
Chuck Todd hey man just give me a phone
call it won't take more than 10 or 15
minutes and really honestly Chuck just
watch this [__] show today and I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna tell you what
you need to do
to make sure that people understand why
there's a difference
between the case of Mike Pence and Joe
Biden and Donald Trump I'm going to show
you it's really [__] simple you just
gotta keep two words in mind when you're
talking to these [__] boxes that's all
you got to do two words two words in
mind when you're talking to them and you
can repeat it over and over and over and
over again
to make sure it sticks in your mind
if that's what you have to do and that's
what you the audience should be doing is
repeating those words over and over now
get to that I'll get to it don't worry
we're gonna do a workshop
in how to make sure people know the
difference
in uh treason and you know
inadvertent document stacking so we're
gonna we're going to we're going to uh
talk about that today
um also I I want to show you
um down Trump over the weekend and Gabe
Sanchez I I don't think he'll be joining
us today he's got an important meeting
he's got to go to
um hopefully it's about the George Soros
deep State bunker that we've been
working on for months and months and
months over a year now so this is a very
important meeting on the construction of
the George Soros deep state antifa
um bunker now
um just as a disclosure this is exactly
where we have the antifa weekly meetings
so if you're out there and you're a card
carrying antifa member
um this is that particular location but
it is an undisclosed address we can't
disclose it so
because of this meeting this morning
Gabe
will not be joining us but he did he did
have a tweet that I want to show
um from Donald Trump well a truth
Gabe Sanchez tweeted about the truth
and the truth post truth social fraud
social post
um I don't know when Trump's supposed to
get on Twitter again everyone was
yelling and screaming last week that he
was gonna be on Twitter and it was going
to be the worst thing ever honestly
that's gonna be a really good thing okay
number one we can all uh get in on the
action right on the platform that we're
on most of us some of us aren't on
Twitter but most of us are on Twitter we
can get into the action get into the
fight right of information now the other
thing that's very significant
about Donald Trump coming to Twitter
which is oh
it's great this is going to be fantastic
I'm telling you I'm telling you this is
gonna be fantastic now I know he got his
um his ability to post over back on
Facebook
Mark Zuckerberg
um thought it was a good idea to let
this Trader post on Facebook
I'm not opposed to it I I think I think
we can out um microphone him to be quite
honest and the reason why is because he
he can't raise any money he can't get
any big donors to give him any money
because they see what he wants too he
wants Fascism and big money they want
plutocracy they don't want fascism
they want plutocracy they want to
control what they want to control they
don't they don't want Donald Trump to
control them they want to control him
see so there's not much interest in the
donor class giving Donald Trump much
money at this point and the re other
reason why is because he's the only
nominee he's the only one he's going to
be the nominee trust me he's going to be
and there ain't nothing these [__]
donor classes can do about it now
he already took over the RNC captured
the RNC I mean he held it hostage so
the donor class is kind of [__] but he
goes after them and he goes after Ron he
calls him decentimonious but he is Ron
DeSantis so and we're gonna we're gonna
do um go over that as well
I I can't wait to read that tweet but
I'll tell you
the reason why I'm excited about Donald
Trump coming back on Twitter
specifically Twitter uh Gabe Sanchez he
has his uh feelings about Facebook I
really don't think it's that dangerous I
actually think it's dangerous
for people not to know the crazy [__]
that this guy's saying to be quite
honest and because then we can't rebut
it you know he just speaks into his
little uh bubble and that bubble can
grow and grow and grow if we're not
careful so we have to pop the bubble but
anyways let's get back to Twitter
the reason why Twitter is so significant
him jumping from fraud social to Twitter
is it will absolutely destroy bankrupt
I mean it'll be like a [__] ghost
town over on true social when he jumped
ship
it's going to absolutely destroy his own
social media platform
destroy it it'll be gone poof out of
here see ya
and there ain't a goddamn thing that he
or anyone else can do about it I mean
I'm sure he'll try to double post
but they're not going to participate
in a conversation over on true social
when they can come to Twitter
and engage with millions of us and by us
I mean the libtards you're goddamn right
they're going to be all up in the
comments as soon as he's there you're
gonna see you're gonna see it light up
like a pinball machine
if you engage at all with Donald Trump
on Twitter at which you should you
should engage
absolutely dropping facts Any Which Way
You Can in the thread and it's gonna
like I said it's gonna light up like a
pinball machine that's the point
that's the point we have to out
microphone them but yeah they're gonna
leave truth social
which is gonna destroy it all right
so
and this is this is Trump's Mo he's got
the best the greatest idea oh it's the
best product ever and then he shits all
over it
because everything that Donald Trump
touches turns to liquid [__] Rick Wilson
says dies I say it turns to liquid [__]
turns the liquid [__] you know it's just
a it's a different way of saying it
let's see what else do we have oh
um we have a clip of Ted Cruz also
talking about the um the documents along
with Jim Jordan
um so we're gonna watch that and then I
have this video I I really didn't intend
to talk about this today I just saw this
video uh on Twitter and I was like what
the [__] is this
it's this this people keep calling him
John hick
um looks like a John Wick kind of video
I don't know this guy set up some
cameras he ain't even got it synced up
really it looks stupid but um anyways
it's a gravy seal if you know what that
gravy seal is you know it's a it's a fat
white dude who thinks he's cool he
thinks he's tough he damn near shoots
himself in the face a couple times
um no I'm serious he damn near shoots
himself in the face it's [__] it's
hilarious it's great great content that
this guy's making I hope I hope he
continues to make it and he and I hope
you know the shooting in the face thing
becomes like a feature of the content
I'm just saying it's great
oh these these [__] trumped up white
dudes watch way too many movies so we're
gonna we're gonna pick that video apart
since it's been getting so many views
um so I'm gonna talk about that
um I'll also want to show
a brilliant video from James Baldwin I
don't know if you guys know the The
Thinker and the activist James Baldwin
but it's crazy that this clip exists
from so long ago
and it absolutely it absolutely
describes
and lays out why why what I was saying
in the first 30 minutes about Tyree
Nichols and the five black officers that
killed him
why that exists
and why if you don't know
that The Tyree Nichols case is about
race you're a dumb [__] and you just are
not listening and you haven't been for
decades you haven't been
you have not been listening so we're
gonna we're gonna show that as well
today so that that's the agenda today so
let's do this let's go because we we got
to round up all the Tweety tweets and
training Trends I got to show you these
videos and this Kevin McCarthy video
because it's it's a pretty long little
video it's a pretty long little kick
clip I'm gonna have to you know it's
gonna take a little bit of time to work
through that one uh for the messaging
and the narrative because we have to
stay on top
of these megalodites in the House of
Representatives that is their position
of power on the national level and we
have to keep our eyes on them we have to
keep laser focused on what they're doing
because our messaging and our narrative
is get is what is going to win back the
House of Representatives in 2024 and the
only way to do that the only way to do
that is to hold them accountable so
let's do that in the shitless Roundup
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
trendy Trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the [__] list
welcome to the [__] list Roundup and
where we round up all the Tweety tweets
and trendy trends of the day and we
gotta keep our thumb on the news right
so that's what we do here on the Tony
Michaels podcast every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting for the Midas
touch Facebook page
look
I want to say thank you to all the
people who have signed up for my patreon
it I I didn't realize how many would
this quickly
um but I want to thank you so much and
I've come up with a way to uh do the
shout out so if you're going to patreon
there's three uh there's three tier well
there's four tiers one's kind of a joke
but there's three tiers go check out the
joked here and I don't know message me
tell me what you think about the joked
here if it's realistic or not if I would
actually shut up for that amount of
money but here's the thing is that
there's a five dollar tier which is
General support a ten dollar tier which
gets you a promotional code for the uh
merch store and then
the last year is a shout out I have
figured out a way I think to do the
shout outs and I I actually think I've
figured out a way to give more stuff in
those other tiers so if you're you've
already joined those tiers thank you
very much we'll be I'll be adding stuff
in those tiers
um I I'm I'm gonna commit myself to
talking to you folks on patreon so if
you want to come over and exceed some
different posts I actually come up with
an idea that I think anyone anyone right
whether it's five ten or twenty dollars
joins the patreon what I'll do is the
videos that I can't get to on the show
because there's so many video clips that
I want to get to on the show I think
what I'll do
is I'll I'll put a post and I'll either
write about it or I'll put a post and
I'll do a quick video of a reaction to
that video
um so you can go see it uh and and
that'll be just on patreon and that'll
be for all tiers and then for the shout
outs I've got a great idea I don't want
to give it away quite yet
um because I kind of want it to be a
surprise because I think it's a great
idea uh and I appreciate your guys's
support and I think it's a great way to
show
um that you guys are supporting the
content here and the content everywhere
on all the social media platforms I
appreciate all the support rather you
come here and watch live every day
whether you're a member of patreon
whether you share this with your family
and friends I really appreciate it that
is one ask I'll I'll ask of you today is
that if you will subscribe to the
YouTube channel that would be fantastic
not only subscribe because we're trying
to get the 20 000 but share it with
three
of your friends or family maybe even
your manga family I mean everyone's got
a little bit of a little bit of manga
family don't they maybe not everyone
most people most people you can also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and download every single episode
that would help us if you download every
single episode every single weekday
Monday through Friday see what happens
is we do the show live and a lot of
people love to watch live but some
people just want to listen to the show
so if you're out there listening thank
you very much for listening on the
podcast directories
make sure that even if you watch live
that you're going and downloading
re-watch re-listen to that first 30
minutes
re-listen I don't know maybe maybe
something will click
in the messaging and the narrative also
you can find us on Twitch the app is
free I don't get paid for the the
download the app
but we're going to be making some
changes over on Twitch if you listen on
Twitch
um apparently you can sign into your
Prime account
and you get a subscription so that's
where we're going to be going with it um
and we're gonna have a subscription
makes it ad free over there because
there's going to be some ads that come
over on Twitch to help us support the
show so if you sign in under your Prime
account you get a free subscription on
Twitch and you can select us or someone
else but watch those over there so
that'll be coming soon but I I really do
ask if you subscribe to the YouTube
channel
keeps us going okay let's see where
shall we start should we start with
should we start with Kevin McCarthy and
then work our way to Jim I don't report
sex crimes Jordan and Ted Cancun Cruz is
that the order we want to go in that's
the order I think I'm gonna go in here
this um clip here
is quite a bit of length
but uh Kevin McCarthy again was on Face
the Nation yesterday
on the Sunday show he again it says in
this clip Kevin McCarthy struggles on
CBS
which he does struggle a bit uh with
Margaret Brennan because she's bringing
facts to the table
and he just has trouble with the facts
and answering questions based on facts
now again I I want to be clear about
something and you got to start telling
people this I don't care if you work
with them if you're friends with them if
they're your family if you [__] meet
them in the line at the grocery store
all right
when they say [__] like I got my opinion
I'm free to have my opinion yeah okay I
agree you're free to have your opinion
but you need to go look up what the
[__] word opinion means
opinion is based in a certain set of
facts right
it's not based on delusion
an opinion is when two people and like
if you're gonna have a debate right
let's say You're Gonna debate someone
rather be formal or informal you have to
at least agree on a certain set of facts
like for instance if you're going to
debate someone on what makes the best
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
you're probably gonna agree on the fact
that it probably has to include some
sort of peanut butter
and some sort of jelly or Jam
like hello think about it
you gotta rely on those set of facts now
your opinions based on those facts those
are opinions but if you have a belief
if you have a belief that there is no
such thing as peanut butter and no such
thing as jelly it's all a deep state
conspiracy and it's all the fake news
media trying to convince you that there
is peanut butter and jelly you do not
have opinions about peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches you do not your opinion
is not an opinion it is a belief you are
in a delusional state of belief but it
is a belief not an opinion go dust off
the dictionary I know you want to ban
them but go dust it off and look up
these [__] words before you start
talking about it right
so there's a good example of the
difference between opinion and belief if
you want to narrow it down to something
easy like a PBJ sandwich okay so let's
go to the Kevin McCarthy clip because
this one's gonna take a bit it's about
four and a half minutes long but
boy does he tell a lot of lies and sling
a lot of Bio [__] so let's take a
listen GOP members denied the results of
the 2020 election you put many of them
on very key committees intelligence
Homeland Security oversight why are you
elevating people who are denying reality
like Okay so this um here's some numbers
here and you know I don't normally talk
about numbers I really don't give a [__]
about numbers it's not hard to know what
the majority of people or what the
majority or what the numbers are it's
not really hard to Snuff that out too
too much I mean if you want to be exact
yeah sure whatever if you want to be
Point spot on and correct like liberals
liberals always want to be exactly
correct right this is our problem a lot
of times when you're debating someone in
the belief and opinion realm is we have
to be absolutely correct and that's why
they get to totally [__] say well
there's no such thing as peanut butter
and definitely no such thing as jelly
those are just deep State can speak
accuracies that the fake news is trying
to push to convince you that you should
you know sexualize and demonize your
children with peanut butter and jelly I
don't know this is how they do it right
does peanut butter and jelly have
genitals I don't know Matt Walsh might
argue that they do okay
so here's some numbers from the House
GOP the America First Nazi party that is
the um one of the problem
is when they put up Republican election
deniers
um folks the only party that's denying
elections party wide
and institutionally is Republicans so
the only real election deniers are
Republicans you uh CBS you do not need
the word Republican there you just don't
election deniers is fine it's a good
enough description
for a bunch of [__] lying cultists
okay so it says 70 percent of the total
house members are election deniers
55 percent
of the house Homeland Security committee
the the [__] the [__] committee
that is designed to protect the security
of our country one of those things being
elections 55 of them are election
deniers now what what does this mean
real and 70 of the Intel and 73 percent
of the oversight which again this is not
surprising that you get it up into the
70s and these numbers on these
committees because their party does not
believe in democracy it doesn't it
doesn't want our Republic it doesn't
want our former democracy it only wants
autocracy in all its lies is designed to
protect the autocrat
the king the Mussolini Jesus Grandpa
Poopypants Donald Trump himself the
entirety of it now here's the thing
is that 70 of the house America First
Nazis aren't really totally election
nighters they are out in the open
it's a [__] act it's a lie they know
it's a lie they know it's all [__]
but they're trying to perpetuate their
Fascism and what better way to
perpetuate their fascism than [__]
lies
so that's uh why we have that let's
continue see how Kevin McCarthy responds
to um his caucus being a shitload of
domestic terrorists who want to tear
down our democracy making them key parts
of our democracy seems kind of funny
that well if you look to the Democrats
they're ranking member Raskin had the
same thing denied Trump or Bush was in
there Benny Thompson
okay there you go there you go I I mean
you can't you got to give it to Captain
McCarthy he can't deny he can't deny
that they're election deniers because
they are so what he has to do is rely on
the old good Republican way of what
about ISM what what about what about
Adam Chef what about him what about him
denying elections denying that Donald
Trump is lying about the election that
he lost that he thinks he won
what election denialism Kevin McCarthy
you [__] scumbag is not
is not
making sure you know the facts and
adhering to that truth okay that's not
election denialism just because your
little man baby down at Mar-A-Lago that
you love to put your knee pads on for is
lying to his supporters and getting them
all riled up to Griff them so he can be
the dictator
and king of our country and get rid of
our democracy
that is not denying any election just
because he wants it to be the way that
it isn't
Kerry lake is is we are not denying
Kerry Lake in election she [__] lost
she had the chance to win she [__]
lost Donald Trump [__] lost that's
the truth and just because you know that
truth and you say that truth does not
mean you're denying anyone an election
they were denied an election by the
voters you stupid bastard stop
gaslighting your stupid [__]
followers and trying to garnish more
support from other Americans who don't
know [__] about politics because that's
what they're doing here folks let me
tell you something let me I'm telling
you what here's what they're doing
here's what they're doing they're not
just talking to their supporters they
know they know they cannot win in 2024
with the support they have it is waning
it is eroding fast fast their support is
eroding fence if you don't think so then
you're not paying attention they won
they won the the Virginia Governor's
race with the [__] lies CRT
that they perpetuated that they that
they [__] rot on their cult
and their cult brought it to Virginia
and convinced normal average people
that yeah CRT is something to be scared
of oh my God you mean they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna teach white
people that they did bad things in the
past
I care I can't feel guilty I don't want
to feel what guilt
so they voted for Junkin in Virginia
which was only a sign leading up to 2022
that we'd have a red wave you remember
that [__]
they use they use that race
to even perpetuate the LIE of a red wave
and it moved it moved because of you
because of Truth
because people are [__] sick of these
fascist Liars they're sick of it they do
not want to put up with this [__]
anymore
and it's moving in that direction so
they're trying to put a Band-Aid
on the wound that is cutting off the
head of Maga fascism in this country
they're trying their damnedest to lie I
mean they are [__] Republicans
they're the party of trump and Santos
let's let's listen
let's listen to the Santos enabler here
put up there 70 did you also be fair and
equal where you looked at Raskin did the
same thing Benny Thompson who's a
ranking member and was the chair these
individuals were chair of the democratic
I'm asking you as Leaders did you did
you ask them did you ask did you ask
them as I mean I know I'm I'm the one
who came to agree to be interviewed
but did you ask did you ask them
what a [__] idiot
it's what about ISM it makes him look
really weak and stupid of course he is
really weak and stupid I mean he traded
away his entirety of his speakership uh
to these these 70 percent of megalodites
that are on the Homeland Security
committee
you made these choices these were your
choices yeah they're my choices but
they're the conference choices but I'm
also there it is there it is did you
hear it okay this is the moment I'm
talking about this is the moment I'm
talking about okay now she's she's
saying you're the speaker you're being
interviewed you're the one here you're
the one in power they voted you
as many times as it took for you to be
speaker because you're such a [__]
loser and you needed George Santos's
vote
but you're the speaker
and these are your choices you and
speaker get to make these choices but he
doesn't
he doesn't this fool does not make these
choices listen to what he says these
individuals will chair in the Democratic
I'm asking you as Leaders
why you made these choices these were
your choices yeah they're my choices but
they're the conference choices but but
but they're they're my choices but the
but but but they're the conference
choices
he he tells you exactly
exactly what he did
exactly he tells you exactly what he did
is he traded away all his power he
traded away the ability
to make sure to make sure
that the Maga Republicans the America
First Nazi party
the election deniers the trumpers
were in power in chairmanships and on
these important committees because he
traded that a way to be speaker it was
the conference Choice it wasn't his
choice yeah I ultimately sign off on it
but they made me do it because if I
don't do it I won't be speaker oh man
it's crazy it's like I'm almost have a
title but I actually don't have the
power I've seated the power to I don't
know a bunch of Nazis huh yeah it's
funny how that works huh Kev let's
continue I'm also asking you when you
look to see just Republicans Democrats
have done the same thing so maybe it's
not denying maybe it's the only
opportunity they have to have a question
about what went on during election so if
you you know what Kevin McCarthy needs
to do
is he needs to spend I don't know a
couple weekends with Tucker Carlson
because he just is not that good at this
right like he's not as good as tuckham's
at this whole well what if well what if
the Democrats actually did this can you
imagine if the Democrats went in 2016
absolutely would storm the capital and
commit violence and try to overthrow our
constitution because Hillary Clinton
constitutionally lost the election
what would happen
why would why wouldn't Democrats do that
is it only Republicans being election
deniers he's not as good
as Tucker Carlson is at this gaslighting
[__]
that's one reason why they really didn't
want him to be the speaker because he's
a dumb [__] folks Kevin McCarthy
is not that great of a leader he really
doesn't even know how to structure the
house works a lot of people are like oh
well he's smart he's been in there bull
[__] [__] the only reason why Kevin
McCarthy even had a chance to be the
speaker is because he was Brandy buddies
with John Boehner okay the guy the guy
loved the sit and I'm talking about John
Boehner John Boehner loved the smoke
cigars and drink brandy with this
[__] fool
they would sit around scratching their
balls talking about how great they were
in high school
and how great they were at robbing
people their entire careers
and how rich they are now that they're
[__] Republican politicians and
drinking brandy and smoking cigars
that's and they enjoyed each other's
company who knows why I don't
but they are Brandy buddies okay
pure and simple go look the [__] up
Kevin McCarthy's a dumb [__] he
does not know how the house [__]
works he does not know how to con count
votes he does not know how to keep his
conference together he's not a leader
he's not and the problem is
he is holding the title in an office of
one of the most powerful leaders in our
country
that's why he's gonna [__] the bed on
the debt limit he's gonna [__] the bed
on keeping the government open he's
gonna [__] the bed because he is inept
he's a dumb [__]
he can't even properly Gaslight people
in this moment I mean they are the best
gas sliders of the best gas sliders
Jesus Christ they have convinced people
that JFK Jr is still alive and he's
going to run with Trump in 2024 and save
the world from the blood-sucking cabal
okay they've convinced people of this
and he he can't even make a great
argument about the what about ISM he's
not even that good at it let's continue
we want to hold Republicans to that
equation why don't you also hold
Democrats why don't you Hold Jamie
Raskin why don't you Hold Benny Thompson
when Democrats had appointed them to be
chair I never once heard you ask Nancy
Pelosi are any Democrat that question
when they were in power in the majority
when the reason why Kevin McCarthy he
she didn't have to ask Nancy Pelosi
um when she was speaker of the house is
because number one she's an actual
leader and she has control over her
caucus and her conference number two she
kept her leadership position meaning she
kept her power to actually control the
Committees she didn't sell it away to be
the speaker and that way she can make
sure that competent people were on those
committees that were serious policy
makers I don't know it's kind of a thing
in government the other thing too is you
stupid [__] is there are no election
deniers in the Democratic Party
we're not denying elections
we're just telling truth about you
[__] trying to steal them you
dumb son of a [__]
and we know the truth now about the
Russian collusion you goddamn right
there was Russia collusion
and you Bill Barr Durham Trump and the
like tried to cover that [__] up
we know we know that McGonagall
the head of counterintelligence with the
FBI covered up that there was collusion
with with Hillary Clinton Donald Trump
and Russia
and he was being paid by a Russian
oligarch daryaposka you [__] scumbag
and now he's going to be prosecuted for
it all right let's continue with little
kev's lies here they were talking about
things going back to 2000 which was it
you're talking about I didn't have the
show back then which is why I'm asking
you no no but that's a pretty good burn
I'm not gonna I'm not I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie
uh uh Margaret there really really Burns
him pretty hard like the reason why I
didn't ask her when she became speakers
because I didn't have to show you
[__] idiot
and uh that's a pretty good one okay
they were in power last Congress so why
why are you talking about questions from
2000 but you're asking me about
questions
the reason why she's asking you
questions you stupid [__] is because
you're the speaker and you're being
interviewed how in the [__] is she gonna
ask Nancy Pelosi questions when you're
the one sitting in front of her you are
a stupid son of a [__]
how how dumbed well I shouldn't even ask
this how dumb they think their
supporters are
I mean they know they're really dumb but
see
Trump supporters aren't going to be
[__] tuning in
uh from from start to finish on CBS
Sunday Morning right Face the Nation
they're just not
but again he's trying to mold the mines
and and Gaslight people out there that
don't know much about [__] politics
now she does a good and and really
anything about the media I mean that's a
real uh a problem in this country it's
not just the media it's the people don't
understand the problems of the media but
you know that's a whole nother [__]
ball of wax that's a whole nother three
hours but let's let's continue you're
asking about any questions for another
Congress so the only thing
these These are members who just got
elected by their constituents and we put
them into committees and I'm proud to do
it
oh so there there he gives away the game
again
gives it away not only not only did
Kevin McCarthy just lie to all look look
at the shitty grin on this
motherfucker's face
look at the [__] grin again I told
you earlier that there was a significant
part of this clip and it was the part
where he admits
it's the part where he admits that yes
it is it is the conference decision to
put these people on committees because I
sold my soul to the devil that is Maga
he sold out his speakership his entire
power to the worst of the worst fascist
in our country and more over in our
government
particularly the House of
Representatives
and here he says the opposite
earlier he said it was my choice I mean
it's the conference choice because
that's who controls me right he admits
that
he didn't know he admitted it but he
admitted it and here he's saying well he
sang opposite it's the constituents it's
this constituents listen your
constituents are voting
for a bunch of fascists based on
delusional lies
again the difference between belief and
opinion
is the problem here I mean we want to
blame we want to blame voters for voting
for these scumbags yeah sure I mean you
know
I'm I'm not saying uh we don't have an
education problem in this country we
certainly do and they're trying to make
a more of an education problem in this
country by taking away even the ability
for teachers to teach children how to
read
or anyone to get them excited about
reading they're really trying to strip
away the ability for people to learn and
have [__] rational thought and
logical thinking in this country and
even deductive reasoning is not up their
alley but here's the thing
is Kevin McCarthy is admitting here
that their lies worked on those
constituents to elect these [__]
fascists into our government
and because they did such a good job
of convincing all these people of all
these lies even ones that are so wild
that JFK Jr and Michael Jackson are
still alive because it's a q Anon World
folks we're just living in it because
they convinced them all these lies and
they voted in all these people based on
lies George Santos is not is not an
outlier
every single one of these Maga
terrorists in our Congress were voted in
because of Lies
not just santos remember that
yes his are wild and crazy and he's got
a whole mountain of lies that he's
dealing with but every [__] one of
them Jim Jordan Matt Getz Marjorie
Taylor green Paul gozard Lauren bobert
the list goes on and on and on and on
with every single one of them they were
all elected by their constituents based
on delusional Maga cult lies
why do you think their main goal is to
get rid of IRS IRS agents that don't
exist investigate a laptop that don't
exist figure out why Joe Biden's a
criminal because he had documents and
how Donald Trump isn't which is not a
thing
why do you think oh inflation which was
going down gas prices which were going
down but they were going up all these
lies that they built to get elected
every [__] one of them not just
santos it's not just George Santos who
was elected based on lies now they're
really pissed off
in New York's third
over Santos's lies the people who voted
for him if we could just figure out a
way to form a narrative to get these
other [__] who are voting for
bobert and green and gozar and Andy
Biggs and and Matt Gantz these Jim
Jordan these [__] scumbag Liars if we
can just get a narrative messaging out
there to make sure that these people
know hey they're telling you lies to get
elected they're lying to you just like
Santos Santos is not an outlier they're
all [__] liars and they got elected
based on lies Kevin McCarthy knows it in
this moment that's what this [__]
grin is about
that's why they love Santas that's why
they're not going to get rid of Santos
that's why they got rid of the Ethics
Committee and by all intents and
purposes is because if they investigate
Santos for his [__] lies they're
gonna have to investigate every goddamn
Republican for their [__] lies to get
elected are you kidding me
he gives away the game every time they
do this
let's listen
let me ask you about some specific scent
um Marjorie Taylor green you put her on
a new subcommittee to investigate the
origins of covet yeah there you go
Margaret lost requirements to the type
of abuse Jews were subjected to during
the Holocaust she called for fauci to be
arrested and imprisoned and she spread
conspiracy theories how's it okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
um I'm Margaret Brennan again fails in
this moment fails completely fails
when she paints up Marjorie Taylor green
as a [__] someone who used to believe
in conspiracy theories listen folks
Marjorie Taylor green went to the White
House on January 5th to help Donald
Trump plan his coup
she was just a newly sworn in member of
Congress and she went to the White House
to meet with the orange Mussolini Jesus
who was planning on overthrowing our
vote and becoming dictator and King and
and the new authoritarian of our country
she went there to plan with him she made
a video she was in the planning process
of overthrowing our government which is
the opposite of Homeland Security
that is the reason why Marjorie Taylor
green should be nowhere near the
Department of Homeland Security not
because she said some stupid [__] about
space lasers in 911 because she's a
[__] domestic terrorist who wants to
end our democracy our homeland security
why can't the media get this right
why why aren't you talking about her
involvement in January 6 why do you
think stat [__] [__] down in Georgia
Marjorie Taylor hoof foot green is so
[__] interested in making sure that
January 6 insurrectionists are not
treated as prisoners because she is one
she is one she's a [__] traitor she's
an insurrectionist
she helped plan the [__] two
how can't we get this right
I don't understand it yeah the [__]
911 conspiracy and her [__] Jewish
space lasers that's all funny that's all
mockable great ha ha we can do that we
can make fun of her [__] three toes
but at the end of the day
she tried to overthrow our the people's
vote
the security of our democracy the
constitution of which the security
stands on
and they can't even bring it up you're
too scared Margaret Brennan to call
Marjorie Taylor green an insurrectionist
at best at best you could call her a
insurrectionist sympathizer for crying
out [__] loud a conspiracy theorist
Jesus Christ if that's the bar [__] all
Republicans meet that [__] bar
of conspiracy theory you [__] kidding
me you ever listened to a republican
talk about anything ever
they're deluded little white privileged
lies and that's not conspiracy theory
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense she tried to overthrow our
government she was part of the planning
she was part of the plot she was part of
the direction to do it that's why she
wants to protect those insurrections
that are in prison now because she is
one
I just don't understand how the media
cannot get this correct just want to
point that out anyone supposed to take
that work seriously and find that work
credible very well you look at all of it
so you have all the questions out there
I think with the Americans you think
these are legitimate questions I think
what the American public wants to see is
an open dialogue in the process this is
a select committee where people can have
all the questions they want and you'll
see the outcome
again this is them talking about the
select committee that's going to
investigate all the investigators the
investigators of the investigators
and the reason why is because they have
to figure out what the investigators
know about them the perpetrators that's
what it's about it's what this
investigation the entire aim is about is
to figure out what the investigators
know about the perpetrators so they can
tell their orange Mussolini Jesus how to
protect himself from Federal indictment
Federal prosecution and a conviction
by trying to overthrow our government
and knowing what documents he destroyed
what documents he stole
and what documents he sold
to try to cover up the coup attempt
and Kevin McCarthy in the house members
of Maga the cult look at this [__]
grin on his face are all part of the
plan
it's all part of the fascist little plan
of their takeover and destruction of our
democracy little by little eroded away
because if their supporters don't
believe they have a democracy when they
take it from them they won't be missing
anything oh God damn I will and I know
you will let's continue
um you know that there is a lot of doubt
about institutions and faith and
institutions oh yeah when you saw what
happened in Congress where they had
proxy voting where bills didn't go
through committees I don't think most
people know what the Voting is oh my God
see again this is so stupid
this is this is really stupid number one
proxy voting has been around for a long
long time one of the reasons why proxy
voting exists in the house is because
there is so many members and a lot of
those members take reprieve back to
their states to represent their
constituents uh in one form or fashion
and proxy voting was developed for that
now it it got more proxy voting during
covet because I don't know they were
trying to prevent disease from spreading
around on the house floor from member to
member
it's not complicated Kevin McCarthy to
understand these things
it's not it just is not
of course truth
and facts get in the way of their
[__] little stupid lies
because really honestly this whole them
getting ready proxy voting is [__]
hilarious because there was no better
proxy voters than Republicans I don't
know if you've ever watched before in
this 117th Congress have you ever
watched a floor vote
there is just as many Republicans proxy
voting as there was Democrats the idea
that Democrats were the only ones that
were proxy voting is [__] dumb it is
stupid because it that is not a [__]
thing frankly if you go back and look at
the numbers you number freaks out there
you liberals who want to be absolutely
correct every time I would imagine that
there was more Republican proxy votes
than Democrats 100 percent sure of it go
look it up fact check me I don't give a
[__] but I'm gonna say it because I
don't need to be 100 correct 100 of the
time for you to know what they truly are
they're [__] hypocrites they use
proxy voting more than Democrats did
now the fact remains they won't have
proxy voting and they don't care the
reason why the Republicans are not
worried about having proxy voting
because they're not going to vote on
anything
they're not going to vote on [__]
the only thing they're going to vote on
is have a quorum to open up the house
floor that's it just to hold the floor
open so they can spew their lives into
our microphones and they're our
microphones it's our official record
that is Our House of Representatives
we elected him partly our fault but that
is ours
ain't gonna vote on [__] so they ain't
worried about proxy voting what are they
going to vote on
they can't even agree that we should
[__] make sure we pay our bills in
this country and increase the debt limit
they should have done did that
they should have done did that I mean
they're gonna do it
no no telling what who they'll leave in
their wake
and what they'll do to the economy
because they want the economy to [__]
be [__] I mean you heard they were
pissed off about high gas prices
remember Joe Biden dips into the spr
the petroleum Reserve
and now they're so oh they're super
pissed that Joe Biden dipped in this
strategic petroleum reserve the spr to
make sure that Americans lowered their
gas prices not only that when when ju
this was a Marjorie Taylor green thing
by the way speaking of lies on the house
floor you know let me
give you some some truth here and
Marjorie Taylor green goes on the house
floor and I got the clip and I ain't
gonna [__] play it and Marjorie
Taylor green goes on the house floor and
she's really upset that Joe Biden's
lowering gas prices oh she's [__]
pissed off at Joe Biden's lowering gas
prices the thing they're really pissed
off about is not the lowering gas prices
because folks even if the [__] gas
prices go up a nickel they're gonna try
to blame Joe Biden it doesn't matter if
it actually has a trend upward or just
goes up a nickel for a day or two and
then goes down a dime they're gonna
blame the price of gas on Joe Biden
regardless of what the trend is or the
prices they don't give a [__] about
truth and none told you that
but here's the thing they're really
pissed off about
Joe Biden and the Biden Administration
did something so [__] brilliant with
the spr
here's why they took the expensive
strategic petroleum Reserve that we paid
a lot of money for
and he released it into the market
flooded the market which which brought
down
the price of fuel at the pump
and then when the price of fuel and the
price per barrel goes down he
re-stocked the spr at a discount rate
so Joe Biden not only did he lower
Americans gas prices by using the spr
which is brilliant and every President
should do this from now on
this is brilliant work
he made four billion dollars in profit
for the federal government we did not
have to pay those taxes we did not we
Joe Biden took that money from oil
corporations right out of their [__]
pockets
by by buying low and selling High you
see
you see four billion dollars
we made
they're always like hey you should run
the country like you run your business
like you run your household
and and we should lower gas prices Joe
Biden does that they're like whoa hey
quit being so smart you make us look bad
when you're smart when you do things
that are smart makes the government
money without having to tax its citizens
as a matter of fact you actually lower
the price of fuel so Americans not only
did not have to pay a single Cent In
more tax than they'd already paid
per gallon
for this four billion dollars that our
government got right they're always
bitching about the debt and balancing
the budget
four billion dollars is what we made
off this sell and buy
of the spr
not only did Americans not pay any more
tax per gallon than what they were
already going to pay
but they paid less per gallon
over that time period
hello with four billion dollars worth of
profit
and they're mad
and the reason why they're mad
is because it worked really [__] well
it worked really well now it's not the
exact answer that every American wants I
mean of course you want to pay five
cents per gallon for your gas which
basically in almost every state almost
the first dollar per gallon is almost
all tax in the first place which I'm not
exactly for but that's just the reality
of it
you're never going to get below a dollar
a gallon no [__] way you're not even
probably gonna get below a buck 25 per
gallon it's just not gonna happen in
Most states I remember years ago when I
could fill up a whole goddamn tank with
less than 20 dollars that's not gonna
happen anymore
but Joe Biden found a way to lower gas
prices for the American people and to
profit
the American people four billion dollars
in the federal government all at the
same time without paying an extra cent
of tax they would otherwise pay for the
gallons of gas that they bought during
that time period brilliant but they
don't like Brilliance they don't like it
they don't like that kind they don't
like when you do the things and fix the
things they're bitching about
they don't like when you point out that
their little [__] fake chaos isn't
real like the IRS agents that aren't
[__] real you didn't fire in the IRS
they just they didn't exist let's
continue
well let's explain but I think it would
be fair to your viewers according to
Gallup of Congress is that 22 percent
approval level of journalists is also
not very high I'll give you that but
doesn't it further wear down credibility
when you put someone who's under State
local Federal and international
investigation as a representative of
your party I'm talking about George
Santos okay so so here he says swalwell
because he thinks swalwell is under
International investigation you are a
stupid [__] and then he thinks
small where was is under federal
investigation uh swallow actually
cooperated with the feds to make sure
uh to to save the security of our
country from a spy you dumb son of a
[__] and
any and he totally knows exactly who
she's talking about
which is George Santos but he can't say
it out loud because he really can't
bring up the fact that he's protecting
George Santos because he really needs
that vote
oh man he needs that George Santos vote
he needs it he needs it bad
uh representative from New York we
should have that discussion so let's
have that discussion you want to bring
up Santos and let's talk about the
institution itself because I agree
wholeheartedly that Congress is broken
and I think you're I think your
listeners or viewers should understand
what proxy voting was because it so he's
gonna go he's going to talk about George
Santos he's going to address the issue
of George Santos by explaining to us the
problem of proxy voting
oh my God this that's the best he's got
are you [__] serious Kevin McCarthy
you I cannot even believe I cannot
believe that his Communications team has
not already figured out a way when he
has asked about George Santos in this
context of how to respond what the [__]
do you do all day
what do you do all day Kevin McCarthy's
Communications team does he have one
are you [__] [__] me they have
this huge [__] issue where George
Santos is a huge [__] Republican liar
a huge [__] Republican liar which
they all are but he's in the spotlight
right now for all these lies for being
under investigation locally state
federal and international investigation
for fraud and crime and Theft
and you don't have a [__] answer
ready when someone asks you about George
Santos your go-to is proxy voting and if
this is if this is folks listen to me
if this is Kevin McCarthy's
Communications team answer
to the George Santos question if this is
how they came up with their their
[__] response
when when the Speaker of the House the
third in line to the presidency
is asked about George Santos his answer
is to go to proxy voting
who the [__] is on this communicate what
kind of [__] are on this
Communications team
Jesus Christ listen folks the good news
about this is and and I'm going to tell
you this from now until 2024 and after
we can beat them in messaging a
narrative we can beat them
it if you're not watching right now and
realize how [__] ridiculous it is
that the Speaker of the House of the
United States House of Representatives
doesn't have a good enough
Communications team that he's going to
go on a Sunday show a national Sunday
show on a network television
and and not have an answer
to why he put a lying scumbag like
George Santos on committees
and what he's gonna do about George
Santos
holy [__] he knew this question was
gonna come at him he knew it the
communications team knows it how in the
[__] did they come up with proxy voting
is their answer
what a weak argument what a weak message
what a weak [__] narrative folks we
can beat them I'm telling you I know
everyone thinks Republicans are good at
messaging and good at narrative they're
not that great at it they just do it all
the time in the loudest volume into as
many microphones as they possibly can
that's why it seems so effective they're
horrible at it it's all based on lies
they're messaging their narrative is all
based on [__] lies you know how easy
that's gonna be to beat
don't be scared of them don't be scared
of their message don't be scared of it
look how weak this [__] is we
can beat them but we can't just sit back
and not do anything we have to form a
messaging and a narrative to beat them
in elections because if we don't win
elections we don't get to do government
and if we don't do government they
definitely aren't because they suck
and it sucks to suck Kevin McCarthy
never took place but I'm asking about
George Santos I know you asked me a
question let me ask because you could
put it to a vote you asked me a question
I'd appreciate if you let me answer so
let's go through this because it's not
one simple answer okay so he's going to
tell us about George Santos here
he's gonna answer okay so let's listen
Congress is broken based upon what is
transpired in the last Congress the
American public wasn't able to come in
to see us
people voted by proxy meaning you didn't
have to show up for work bills didn't go
have to go through committee so what I'm
trying to do is open the people's house
back for the people so their voice is
there so people are held accountable so
that's why George Santos
it is not being scrutinizing the Ethics
Committee
is because he wants to make sure there's
no proxy voting
anymore that's that's the reason
what the [__] does that even mean Kevin
McCarthy what does that mean Kevin
McCarthy's communication stamp what the
[__] does that mean
the reason why George Santos
that [__] Liars is able to walk
around and be a member of the business
committee small business committee
because he is he has run successful
frauds that has defrauded veterans
out of money to save their their [__]
pets lives
he's defrauded his campaign
he defrauded on his filing lied
that's why because you need to get rid
of proxy vote what the [__] sense does
that make
what kind oh it doesn't the reason why
it doesn't because they don't have a
good argument for this that is why I
keep telling you Santos is not an
outlier he is just a Norman's normal
average everyday Republican so now as I
just had in the last week for the first
time in seven years every member got
through it if you got a third of your
caucus to vote to ask him you could do
so do you don't think you could get your
Republicans to do that I wasn't finished
answering the question I wasn't finished
avoiding the question is what he means
I'm trying to avoid the question because
I don't have an answer because every
single one of my caucus members every
one of them are just as big as Liars as
George Santos and if I scrutinize George
Santos then I would have to scrutinize
the rest of my caucus and they all would
have to resign we would have to remove
every [__] one of them Jim Jordan
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert Matt
gatz Andy Biggs Paul gozar myself Steve
scalise all of them from Power if we
scrutinize them the way that you want me
to scrutinize George Santos just saying
so if every single new person brought
into Congress was elected by their
constituents but their constituents have
done has lined their voice to the
American public so those members can all
serve on committee now what I'm trying
to do is change some of these committees
as well like the Intel committee is a
different thing so you're just not going
to answer the question I asked well no I
no no he's not going to answer the
question he didn't have an answer for it
he clearly did not prepare for the
question that you were going to ask
which was obvious that you were going to
ask him
clearly
he did not prepare at all he has no
answer for why he wants to make sure I
mean I know why do you know why let me
you want to know why he's protecting
George Santos
because George Santos is a vote for him
that was the promise that was the trade
you vote for me I'll make sure I'll make
sure you don't go through the excess
committee I'll make sure you stay in
congress as long as possible
you're not going to win your next
election because you pissed off all your
voters
but I'll make sure also
that you are not an average Republican
you're going to be an outlier but I'm
not going to get rid of you
and that's what we have to do with our
messaging and our narrow the
pro-democracy Coalition we have to make
every [__] one of these goddamn Maga
cult Liars George Santos every single
one of them including Kevin McCarthy
that's why I do this show that's why I
give you this breakdown you know you'd
think I just took uh 30 40 minutes to
break down a four minute video for no
[__] reason Hills no
oh let's see okay let's let's move on to
the other Maga cult Liars yeah damn
we're 35 minutes into the second hour I
mean I had time to get to some of these
clips now let's see this is Jim Jordan
this is only a minute long
and it's pretty simple here of
how to combat this [__] fool and this
is on Meet the Press on NBC uh Chuck
Todd as you know he he sucks at uh
follow-up questions he sucks at
questions but he really sucks at
follow-up questions and he really sucks
it like fact checking and telling
someone that they're a [__] liar in
real time he's horrible at that now he
tries here in this clip he really does
try uh but he misses the mark let me
show you why what about this raid uh on
on Donald Trump the amount of time there
was nine months between the initial
action that the archives made for a
request of documents before they even
turned it over the justice department
The subpoena was issued 60 days before
they actually uh executed The subpoena
and more importantly the only time the
public found out about it is because
Donald Trump told the public about it
this was not some sort of the you
painted as a picture of the FBI did this
this and this within hours of each other
when it was actually a year and a half
of Donald Trump not complying with any
of the requests from National Archives a
year and a half this is not some sort of
uh proof that somehow that they've
weaponized and playing politics over
here they're rated Okay the reason why
Jim Jordan is smiling here is because
Chuck Todd did not do two things
that every single journalist should be
doing every single time they're talking
about the Donald Trump's documents case
two things let me let me let me get
bigger on the screen here so you can
hear me and you should be talking about
it every single time every time someone
brings it up every time someone's in
your thread every single time two words
two words only intent and obstruction
intent and obstruction intent and
obstruction Chuck Todd Brees he he kind
of says it he wants to say it look the
reason why the FBI went to Mar-A-Lago
and had a search warrant to go get our
documents back for the doj and Nara is
because a federal judge issued a search
warrant based on three criminal statutes
three of them he broke three
[__] crimes
that is the suspicion suspection of
trump he
he more than likely there was enough
evidence for the judge to say whoa yeah
he totally [__] stole these documents
and he's totally obstructing it was
Criminal Intent and criminal obstruction
it's not complicated to understand why
the FBI went to Mar-A-Lago and raided it
raided it
for the documents
because there was three criminal
statutes that he criminally with
Criminal Intent broke those three
statutes including criminal obstruction
folks intent and obstruction why Chuck
Todd just can't say that to Jim Jordan's
face he's a [__] criminal you know
he's a criminal you're harboring a
criminal you're protecting a criminal
because he's your orange Muslim Jesus
but this roundabout Ray that Chuck Todd
goes about this is kind of ridiculous
intent
and obstruction
intent and obstruction it's Criminal
Intent it's criminal obstruction folks
that is why the FBI went to Trump's
shitty ass Golf Course went to his
apartment his Corner apartment in that
shitty golf course and went and got our
[__] documents back because he had
Criminal Intent when he stole them
any criminal tent of obstructing to get
them back but let's listen to how Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan frames it
up he knows how to hide crime oh Jim
Jordan oh Jim Jordan ah he knows how to
obstruct a criminal investigation Jim
Jordan's oh man he's got experience
rated Trump's home they haven't raided
Biden's home because Biden didn't defy a
subpoena Congressman he defied a
subpoena by the way he had 60 days
before they actually executed again
check Todd misses the mark
they raided they raided Trump's home and
not Joe Biden's home and the reason why
the FBI didn't raid Joe Biden's home or
Mike Pence's home
is because there was no um
what's the words intent and obstruction
that is the reason why the reason why
the FBI Jim Jordan you [__] scumbag
they did not raid Joe Biden or Mike
Pence's home is because there was no
Criminal Intent
and there was no criminal obstruction
you stupid [__]
you stupid bastard Jim Jordan but they
know this he knows this that's why he's
smiling when Chuck Todd doesn't
challenge him on it that's why he's got
that [__] grin on his face he he
you missed it you didn't call him a
criminal you won't call him a criminal I
dare you but you won't
you won't you won't call him a criminal
speaking of the Criminal
let's look at the uh actually you know
what let's go to this clip of Ted Cruz
first because Ted Cruz talks about the
documents
um this is hilarious and there's another
clip of Ted Cruz but I I think this
one's probably the the most important uh
in his little lies here he's on Fox news
on Sunday uh and and
uh he talks about the amount of boxes
and then he tweets out this clip but
let's watch Hunter Biden is not an
expert on Ukraine he's not an expert on
Eastern Europe he's not an expert on
Russia but but that email did help get
him on the board of Barista it did help
get him paid 83 000 a month because it
it showed a level of expertise not
coming from him but he was getting it
from somewhere that's clearly from some
sort of briefing we don't know whether
it was a classified briefing or not but
that is the sort of analysis that is
often within a classified briefing and
Ted Cruz knows exactly what happened and
what didn't happen here he's full of
[__] [__] he knows this is all
[__] that's why he said maybe maybe
maybe not I mean we're just asking
questions why can't we ask questions I
mean even though I know the answer maybe
you don't know the answer and I want to
steer you in a direction where you'll
know the wrong answer maybe that's why
I'm asking these questions it's really
[__] dumb well 400 Biden lamp top
[__] this is all gonna [__] the bed uh
we're gonna find that out now he's gonna
he tries to tie the documents to a
hunter Biden's email partner business
partner looking uh oh suspiciously like
it came from classified info as if Joe
Biden stole the documents to give him
the hunter Biden so he'd get a job at
barism or some [__] listen I thought the
reason why I thought the reason why
Hunter Biden got the job at breezeman is
because Joe Biden was the vice president
I thought that was the reason why is to
have influence with the vice president
and I didn't think it was a trade for
classified information that's not what
they were telling us that's not what the
original narrative around the stupid
laptop talk was right no it wasn't it
wasn't they're all over the map and the
reason why they're all over the map
because they ain't got the truth they
don't know the truth they're [__]
dummies they're making [__] up just like
Ted Cruz makes this [__] up right here
and and this email is unusual in the
hunter Biden emails there there's a
level of Scholars ship and air Edition
that if it magically appeared somehow it
doesn't appear in the other emails he's
sending the obvious question is what was
he cutting and pasting from what was his
source and it raises the natural
inference that Hunter Biden had Direct
access to these classified documents we
do know that Joe Biden it seems
everywhere they search for classified
documents for Joe Biden they find it
whether it is Wilmington home his
Rehoboth Beach home whether in his
garage next to his Corvette whether in
the room next to his garage next to us
which are all in the home
those aren't separate locations you see
how he does that stupid [__] you see I
gas lights and gets these people like oh
there's they're get thousands of places
Jill Baden owns 15 homes he even flies
down to Cancun when Delaware gets a
snowstorm wait that might be some other
person all right keep going this
Corvette weather in the Penn Biden
Center it seems he leaves classified
documents wherever he goes and we also
know that Hunter Biden at times was
declared his residence to be those very
same places and so I believe the natural
Next Step that is necessary is for the
FBI to examine the 1850 plus boxes of
documents from Joe Biden's Senate tenure
that's at the University of Delaware and
I also believe it is critical for the
FBI to search Hunter Biden's homes Home
and Office residences to make sure there
are no classified documents there given
all the evidence that's piling up we
need to ascertain who's had access to
what and when again
I want you to remember two words two
words well in this case three no intent
no intent
no obstruction no intent no obstruction
no intent no obstruction with trump it
was intent and obstruction
now my question to Ted Cruz any there's
there's more to this clip but I'm not
gonna play the other clip
my question to Ted Cruz is hey hey [__]
when are you gonna let the Department of
Justice search your home for classified
documents
Senator Ted Cruz when are you gonna let
him you got access to classified
information when are you going to let
them search your email
if you get typed out any [__] emails
that might have maybe encryptically or
you copied and pasted I don't know maybe
your staff help you write like they do
all the time or some [__] huh I wonder I
wonder if there's any of those that
would lend your power as a senator to
get someone a position
on a private company I wonder I just
wonder I don't know I'm just just
thinking out loud I mean shouldn't we be
asking these questions shouldn't we know
shouldn't we know if United States
senators are using the access to their
email and access to classified
information to make sure that people
have key positions in private companies
shouldn't we know this
should shouldn't we have the ability as
the American people to have the
transparency that a senator like Ted
Cruz we know
if he's acting corruptly shouldn't we
know this shouldn't we know if those if
the boxes and paperwork and the [__]
that Ted Cruz takes to Cancun in his
suitcase
has classified markings on it or not
why why are we being demonized just for
asking these questions
ah you [__] scumbags nah Ted Cruz I
can't wait for the FBI to search your
home for classified documents
okay let's go to the um I gotta Play
This One Clip uh I gotta get to it but
but I wanna show you this uh uh true
social post and Gabe Sanchez put up
um
it's from Donald Trump Gabe Sanchez he's
not here today but he's here in style
because of his
his tweet here
he says Trump is quote America First all
the way except when it comes
to his businesses
and his bank accounts
because here's the uh yeah let me take
this down so you can see the full
statement I'll take the patreon thing
off the screen right now again if you
want to if you want to look at the
patreon to see if you want to join as a
member uh if you want to check it out
again we're going to be adding some some
benefits and stuff to the tiers let's
take that down now but just go to the
Tony michaels.com the Tony michaels.com
you can find the patreon link at the top
or just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels check out uh the patreon
community that is happening over there
now more and more people are joining
dozens of people joined last week so
thank you very much to those folks and I
got a special surprise for the people
who joined the shout out the 20
patreon tier I'm gonna surprise coming
this week of how we're going to give you
the shout outs anyways let's go back to
Grandpa poopypants's true social here
this is hilarious he's freaking out
because he can't get the Club for Growth
to give him any money
and they're refusing to support his
candidacy as the President of the United
States now that won't last long folks
the Club for Growth will support him
eventually just like the NRA supported
him eventually
just like the right to lifers
supported him eventually he will be the
Republican nominee there's no question
he will be there's no other Contender I
know you think Ron DeSantis is but he's
not he's not going to choose to destroy
his political aspirations for 2028 by by
getting banged up by Donald Trump in
2024. he's working hard I'll tell you
Rhonda Santos is working hard to
position himself in case Trump Falls
to fill the spot Ron DeSantis is going
to make sure if Trump
makes a makes an out quick that he can
enter the race quickly
he's going to continue his Hitler ways
down in Florida to make sure of that but
I don't see him entering the race
anytime soon okay so Donald Trump says
this on fraud social he says the club
for no growth
is a globalist group ah they're
globalist now that have been taking been
taking to the cleaners I've been taking
to the cleaners for years we worked
together for a period but they can't get
away from Jenna Europe Asia
and Parts Unknown which China Europe
okay I I can't I can't figure out why
you'd have to explain to this idiot
um what China the difference between
China and Asia and what those are China
is a country Asia anyways uh when I uh
one's a continent one's a country in
that continent but you know who's
counting
um they know I like he just wants he
just wants the racism right he's like
Europe which is mostly white so he's
gotta add in Asia Ryan he's gonna add
that in now you know I won't play the
get that game I am America First all the
way
so he's he's saying Club for Growth is
now
a Chinese puppet and he did take their
money oh he took the money but he's not
going to anymore that's only way we make
America great again Ron Des
sanctimonious here we go with the Ron
DeSantis stuff you want to know why you
want to know why Rhonda santis is not
going to enter this race here it is
here it is Donald Trump will eat his
lunch in a primary here it is Rhonda
sanctimonious who I made governor in
both the primary and the general is also
a globalist
and so are his donors
Jeb low energy quote Bush was next to
him last week check past I'm thinking
he's checked like check jab Bush pass
maybe check Ron DeSantis as fast here's
the thing here's the reason why Rhonda
santis will not enter the race unless
Donald Trump is really weak he can't win
or he's out of the race the reason why
is because Ron DeSantis cannot speak
like this towards Donald Trump
got it let's listen to me when I tell
you this here's the reason why Rhonda
santis cannot run for president at this
moment in time he cannot
he cannot
he cannot talk like this
about Trump
he can't do it if he does he won't win
Ron DeSantis is smart enough to know
that Trump is also aware enough not
smart enough but aware enough to know
this that he can drag down Ron DeSantis
all he wants he can punch at him call
him a globalist call him antifa whatever
he wants
and Ron DeSantis cannot do [__] about it
the reason why is because Maga is a
fascist cult and Donald Trump is still
their [__] leader okay
get it through your thick [__] skulls
Donald Trump is the leader of the cult
he is the Republican Jesus he is the
mango Mussolini Jesus he is the Cheeto
DUS King q and honor the manga King all
right
there is no way that Ron DeSantis can
have shots fired to Donald Trump like
Donald Trump can shoot at Ron DeSantis
and that means
Ronda santis cannot enter the race
unless something like that changes and
if you think that's going to change
I don't think you've been paying
attention enough
I mean if I was around DeSantis right if
I'm I if I'm a [__] fascist scumbag
right let me just say for a second and I
want to control the world and I want to
make America the the fourth Reich right
let's just say that your aspirations is
Ron DeSantis
and you know all you have to do is wait
four years
four years you know you know that Donald
Trump is going to be the nominee
because he's got the cult
the cult's with you but it's not gonna
be against him right Rhonda Santos know
the Colts with him and he loves he loves
that tail that Wags The Dog Ron DeSantis
does but he knows he it won't he can't
go against the cult the cult will be
with him but he can't go against him
so he knows Trump is going to be the
nominee he knows that Biden's going to
be the nominee folks Joe Biden is going
to be the Democratic nominee stop
talking about other [__] people
running for president it is not gonna
happen
okay Joe Biden is going to be the
Democratic nominee the president United
States is the incumbent president will
run
as a nominee
and Donald Trump will be the nominee in
the Republican Party mark my words
Ron DeSantis knows these facts these are
the facts that are right before him
today unless something changes
that's what it is today unless something
changes
Rhonda Santos is willing to wait four
more years
especially if Biden wins and he can
paint him in some kind of scary Marxist
socialist who's trying to destroy our
country and make us communist
that way in 2026 he can announce he's
running and he can start running because
Trump's out of the way then Trump is out
of the [__] way by 2026 Trump will
already be facing his criminal trials
that's right
Trump will be in the in the throes of
criminal trials all over the country
more than likely in a lot of federal
courthouses
Ron DeSantis knows these facts he sees
the he sees what's happening Ron
DeSantis is not a dumb [__] he
is unfortunately dangerously smart
so
just be aware
that Ronda santis will get in the race
he's going to position himself
behind Donald Trump without Vaseline
just in case he falls to enter the race
but if he can't take that opportunity
he'll run in 2026 for 2028 because he's
going to want to run against Gavin
Newsom and so he's gonna that that
that's gonna be his anyways
we don't have to go that far
okay let's let's go to this clip that I
want to show you of this gravy seal
and oh my God this I just saw this clip
I'm like what in the [__] is this [__]
um
it's it's from uh let's see the the uh
the big red kelt uh posted this video I
don't know where they found it I guess
on Tick Tock or some [__]
um it's crazy [__]
it's this um trumped up white dude and I
said these trumped up white dudes watch
way too many movies
because apparently there's a scene in
John Wick or this this is happening
um but this guy this
this is funnier this is funnier and [__]
this guy's dumber than dog [__] he
almost shoots himself a couple times in
the face I'm not kidding you and he
thinks he thinks he's gonna slice and
dice a mannequin
um like you put peanut butter and jelly
on toast watch watch this guy watch this
game and then the music you know makes
it that much better I gotta turn it down
though because uh they might knock me on
the music
[Music]
oh my God this is God's plan okay I'm
gonna mute the music uh and just play
this um and narrate because there's one
point uh he's shooting over his shoulder
here now I don't I I don't this this gun
does not have much recoil so this is
definitely not a real uh firearm and I
don't even know if they're real knives
because he really doesn't know how to
use a knife
um you know he's he's softly softly
um molesting the mannequin with the
machete that he has
molesting the mechanic the molesting the
mannequin with the machete say that 12
times fast
um and then he's shooting over his
shoulder in his face at the other dummy
the other mannequin that's here and he
almost he fires inadvertently in the air
right
right here right there he misfires boom
he's just lucky he doesn't have an
actual cameraman or a cameraman would be
[__] dead
um it's surprising that this guy isn't
dead now this is great content folks
here's why
um I encourage all these trumped up
idiots to do this oh yeah [__] yeah get
out in your yard where there's no one
around make sure you can't fire
inadvertently and pump some idiot or
maybe one of your my relatives
with one of your stray bullets and just
do this in your yard all day oh practice
this because this is what is going to
make sure that
um you
1776ers overturn our democracy and turn
it into the fascist state that you want
you [__] white racist look at this
guy what the [__] with the outfit he
can't hardly get the Clips in and then
he's firing all kinds of places he
stabbed the same mannequin 14 times
so he didn't kill the mannequin first
right he's got to stab it 14 times
before it's dead so he he can't even
properly kill a mannequin
um at close range the other thing too is
you know
I wasn't in the military and I really
don't know much about um hand-to-hand
combat with Weaponry but let me tell you
something about a handgun
um when I was a kid because we had we
had hunting rifles we didn't have
handguns our guns when I was a kid they
were they were meant to kill deer and
turkey we didn't have the type of
enemies that a [__] idiot like this
would have to help protect him from the
enemies I mean we kept our [__] doors
unlocked when I was a kid we we didn't
we didn't lock our doors we didn't lock
our car we left the keys in in the
[__] ignition of our cars in the
driveway
our guns were not for protection folks
that is not what our guns were for when
I was a kid
we didn't think oh someone was going to
break in and steal our [__] we had the
keys in the ignition of the cars in the
driveway we left all the doors unlocked
when we weren't there we left the doors
unlocked I don't even know if we had a
[__] key to our house when I was a
kid okay
what kind of [__] enemies these
people got I don't know
that they gotta have protection where
they got knives and they got a practice
in their yard with dummies and
mannequins
to try to make sure that if the if the
mannequin apocalypse the mannequin
zombies take over the Universe I have no
[__] idea
this is the dumbest [__] I've ever seen
and really honestly it's surprising that
this guy has not killed himself and I
want him to keep doing this content so
if you know who this is and you find
their account send it to me I want to
see his content and the thing is I'm
really looking forward to the season
finale in this content
um of this white moglodyte
oh my God the [__] is wrong with these
people holy [__] thank you for joining
us today here on the Tony Michaels
podcast as you do every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from the mind is
touch Facebook page do me a favor
subscribe to the YouTube channel no
matter what platform you're on right now
whether it's twitch
um and Twitter Facebook go subscribe to
the YouTube channel and share it with
three of your friends three your family
members we're trying to get to 20 000
subscribers please help me in that
effort also I want to thank again
all the folks that have joined the
patreon and all you folks who have went
and checked out the patreon I'm going to
be adding more to it uh we're gonna try
to do some things over there that's just
for the the people who uh are are in the
paying members of the patreon I'm gonna
try to give you some more content over
there
um videos that we don't that we don't
get time for here on the show might uh
either just show you the video and give
you a written response or maybe I'll do
a video response depending on the time
but I'm going to try to get more of
those videos that I find more of the
clips that I find that I don't get time
for on the show to show you so go check
out the patreon there's a 5 10 and 20
tier the 20 tier you get a personal
shout out for me and I I think I figured
out a great way to do this and we're
going to start this this week
um so I don't want to ruin the surprise
but I want to tell you all the people
who are getting shout outs I've got I
think I've got a cool way to do this
um so you guys get a shout out on all
the social media so everyone go to the
patreon check it out even if you don't
join no problem go check it out see what
you think tell me your suggestions tell
me your suggestion what would you like
to have out of the patreon and I
appreciate everyone who's joined also
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google you know the show is free
here not just on YouTube but it's also
free on all the podcast directories it's
absolutely 100 free to listen to me two
hours every single week game there's so
many ways to listen or watch so make
sure you're giving us great reviews over
on the directories if you're listening
there while you're subscribing follow us
on on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod also
follow us on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and download that Twitch app
see if you like twitch who knows you
might like it you might not but you
might like it over there on Twitch it's
again the app is free you can watch us
for free on Twitch everyone and
I don't I haven't talked to Texas Paul
yet in full disclosure about tomorrow I
know I don't know if I I don't know if
he's going to be back on I don't know if
he's fully back from vacation so I'll
let you know maybe I'll tweet at him
I'll tweet at him see if he's if he's
ready tomorrow or not or if we're gonna
have to wait till next week but I have
some great guests lined up this week
we're gonna have some great guests for
you live this week we're going to talk
to some people
so do not you do not want to miss an
episode this week it's going to be a
great week great shows everyone until
tomorrow same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon